اا طبعا السيف الاكروا هو عمل جهد جبار
جدا في كتابه بحث فرنسي كتب كتابه باللغه
همم الفرنسيه انا قريت كتابه باللغه
الانجليزيه والعربيه الكتاب جدا ممتاز
ولما قالت الترجمه العربيه اصدمت من
جودتها بامانه همم
من خلال جلسته مع الاسلاميين والصحاويين
خلقت حاله التعاطف في الكتاب القارئ
يشوفها همم حاله تعاطف وكانه النمش معهم
طبعا مو مطلوب بدها ان هي دين بس همم حاله
التعامل مع بعض
المطلوب
هل السبب اجان مره ثانيه زي ما سوى
الشيرازيل هم فاتحين على الاعلام لان
نتذكر الوقت الاجابه فيمكن اللي فتحونه
الابواب لكن الوقت طبعا تعرف ما في موقف
رسمي من السوريين والاخوان عندك كان
متمكنين فيمكن هم اللي يفتحوا له الباب
وقعدوا معه وجلسوا في المجالس والسلام
وهؤلاء جماعه
كمان انا اكرس روايتي من الغرب يصير في
اعاده انتاج يعني انا اقول ان انا وانا
بجيك يعني بقول لك روايه بشكل مباشر لان
الصحفي الفلاني ما حتقبلني يكفي اني انا
مرتبطه باسمي بس لما تجيك على اسم ستيفان
ولا مايكل لا يطلع لها شكل حلو يعني فلذلك
هذا اللي صاير